so it is the best we can do
Trump saying half the time is that where
we're at is that where the bar is I
think the bar is lower than that I mean
there's the there's five days in a week
bill so like the the crazy Trump I think
it's the Monday Wednesday and Friday
we've seen like Friday tray in the
Tuesday and Thursday flip No Deal Arpaio
thing tells us a lot about this
president he went outside the normal
process here normally when you're gonna
pardon somebody you go through the
Justice Department the person may
express a little bit of remorse and and
you kind of do it this way or you wait
until the sentencing is up this none of
this happened right Joe Arpaio was
gleeful about his activities Donald
Trump said he was punished for doing his
job so let's be clear about what his job
that Joe Arpaio had done he violated the
Fourth Amendment rights of citizens of
the United States as well as residents
by pulling them over because they maybe
kind of looked a little bit illegal
immigrant II and then would detain them
and then hand them over to the feds in
defiance of a court order
month after month after month so if
you're going to go and you're gonna
suspend the normal process to pardon
that guy you're saying you're telling
every law enforcement in the country
look civil liberties don't really matter
here as long as you are you know
breaking things a little bit if you're
going after illegal immigrants and
immigrants that's who this president is
he'll do that no teleprompter he'll do
that as a rally that is the core of his
personality it's something to worry
about it's an insight into an actual
ideology that Donald Trump might have
and it's not a Republican or
conservative ideology it's the ideology
that serves him as an autocrat right he
attacks the Fourth Estate in the median
tries to break that down remove trust
that people can have as the media as
their protector he's already been
talking about the judicial system as
being activist right in the ninth
circuit in all of these instances he
doesn't like the judiciary which has
been the last place of resort for people
of color
immigrants in particular other people of
color and women when it comes to any
civil liberties issues so by pardoning
Joe Arpaio a vigilante who flouts the
rule of law Trump has said it no longer
matters if you are holding to a standard
a rule of law and it scares frankly is
very scary for people of color
to try to understand where can you go
for recourse if it's the president is
going to override the judicial system
yeah you know all the talk about
building the wall whoever is gonna but
they don't need the wall just making
life miserable and terrifying for anyone
of dark skin has actually worked a lot
longer not coming inning by the way long
before Donald Trump became president
when Barack Obama was president illegal
immigration from Mexico was going down
its own Trump's wall will only slow down
their departure and maybe mine I don't
know but I think I'm their power thing
yes he has a soft spot for white
nationalists we already knew that and
yes he wants to flat the rule of law and
he's a autocrat wannabe I think there's
a larger game here he's playing he wants
to send a signal to the targets of the
Moller investigation that if you hold
tight and don't roll on me I'll pardon
you oh wow who's Muller is going after
Trump associates first that's what we're
doing these things all about Russia I
think it is it all roads lead to Russia
it's the Rosetta Stone if his poor
mangled brain is he's always thinking
about Russia and that's what I do think
he well he's right to be worried about
that yeah because I mean whatever we
know about it
he knows way more and he knows what he
did and what he did was bad what he did
was basically he owed Russia money and
instead of paying them he gave them
America okay